hey everyone my name is Ben Bishop
producer for NDA 2K15 and I'm here to
talk to you about some of the cool new
things we're doing in my career last
year you're able to interact with LeBron
James and this year we wanted to kind of
take it to the next level so we went out
and captured audio from players from
every NBA team so no matter where you
are in your career no matter what you're
doing you'll have people to talk to and
interact with you so here's a sneak peek
at just a little bit of what we've done
this year take a look
oh come on man let me have this one I
did all the little things you always
talking about hustle effort Relentless
fair enough keep it up and the wins will
follow
hey I'm just one piece man but I'ma do
my part work hard and do the little
things to help this team win good with
attitude I think you'll fit right in I
had a teammate hold me back he told me
to chill sounds like a wise fella to win
in this league you need all hands on
deck hey I know you saw me locking up
out there right no I saw you doing what
you're paying to do play good defense
whenever you're on the court I'm just
saying we all could have done more I
could have helped out on defense more
maybe made the extra pass none of us are
perfect that's right we all got to get
back to work and the winds will take
care of themselves
Hey listen up I had a blast playing with
you this year you came a long way so now
you got some decisions to make where
you're going to play
we're gonna call home for the next year
or so my advice is just trust your gut
you know what it feels like when you see
it
I'm gonna highlight you later in the
summer to see what your mindset all
right so those are just a few examples
of what we've done this year with the
mode so be sure and check out NBA 2K15
coming October 7th